qu'est ce que tu en penses bas et qu'il
est magnifique et vola bel et bien fait
c'est une oeuvre a été reconstituée par
un artiste finlande et voilà c'était
dans le cadre des boréales en fait ça te
plaît i am ozzy manama
project
il y prône toutefois protection ignore
m farm 4 fame conforter cette oeuvre
éphémère devrait durer tout de même une
dizaine d'années dans le parc du château
jacquot perdu est un artiste qui expose
aussi au canada au brésil
c'est sûr
et maintenant retrouvons sabine daniel
et bertrand goulet au cargo avec
artistes normands wax tailor
alors jacques je suis avec wax taylor
qui a commencé sa tournée française pour
ce cinquième album by any means
necessary un double c'est un double
album première question pourquoi un
double à savoir qu'il ya la partie
chantée deuxième album c'est uniquement
musicale mais en fait c'est parce que je
suis quelqu'un qui abandonne la partie
studio vraiment de façon instrumentale
toutes les parties vocales et les titres
vocaux en fait c'est ça arrive toujours
dans un deuxième temps il ya toute une
trame instrumental qui pensait on va
dire dans un travail laborantins et
solitaire et je pense que l' approche
musicale et instrumentale elle est
intéressante c'est à dire qu'à des
titres qui s'autosuffise les titres qui
sont disons plus de l'ordre du squelette
instrumental où on sent qu'il manque une
voix mais je pense que ça amène à
écouter les titres différemment dans
l'instrumentation après on réécoute la
version vocale différemment
beaucoup d'invités dans cet album
comment ça se passe alors sur scène à
beaucoup de monde aussi sur scène
c'était le préalable
non j'ai une belle équipe là sur la
route on est on est 17 entre sur la
route dont un artiste donc 4 4 musiciens
j'ai un batteur c'est chouette et ça
donne vraiment une relecture de l'album
on live qui qui prend des accents encore
plus organique avec la batterie avec les
guitares il ya une énergie rock en fait
qui est intéressant de combat
charlie hebdo
ouais enfin de l'album à peu près puisse
cesser la période
ouais c'est cette période et c'est vrai
que j'ai eu besoin de faire un album
exutoire droit quelque chose qui soit
attribué petto c'est plus positif
on a tous sera ce moment en fait où on a
besoin d'eux on a besoin d'être d'être
loin de prendre un livre d'aller voir un
film d'aller dans d'aller courir dans la
forêt je sais pas faire ce qu'on a envie
de faire
moi je suis musicien j'ai eu envie de
faire de la musique j'avais envie de me
imaginé voilà sur les routes des états
unis est un pays qui m'inspire beaucoup
merci pour cet instant partagé parce que
le concert ces vases tout de suite
quasiment sans rire et bonne tournée
merci